finally here we go
sitting here oh you have bothered only
pickpocket information
haha I can keep that too
yeah something me where's Ernie retreat
what next mission will call you all
right it's not a hundred I'm just
grabbing the top wait
all right there yet all right kid good
luck out there in here you going tonight
I can't tonight I got the astark
internship what's up guys this is my
report for tonight
I stopped a glance at flight school hey
could you do me a favor pull Amida
there's anybody fight I helped this old
lady and she bought me a churro
so how was nice I just feel like I could
be doing more wait a minute you guys on
the real event just hope gives it away
new move I'm working on some better
don't rain
he's working for crazy dangerous
listen there are people who handle this
sort of thing can't you just be a
friendly neighborhood spider-man
activating parachute
the world to change invoice time leakage
to
my can't prove myself you a Spanish
Queen you got to get better at this part
of the job oh I'm inseminated
where you going what are you hiding
Peter
[Music]
I'm just kidding anger by
there's a ton of other social systems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocols you could
mister start treating me like a kid but
you are a kid yeah you can stop a boss
with his bare hands
whoa look at that new guy who's that
address definitely I gotta go
clarify when Captain America and I stole
his shield not throw it at him how are
you thinking I was those amazing things
never have mr. Harris and I just sort of
slipped in Hades a second come in Riften
walsall the rich and the powerful I
don't care about I with pick up a strand
with these they're table scraps these
alien bastards it's tough you got to use
the stuff they use the world's change
time we change to wait on retreat next
mission will call you it's a little more
mentoring to be a real asset to you it's
not a hug I'm just grabbin to talk wait
oh all right good good luck out there
someone is collecting stuff from
Avengers battles and building these
crazy weapons this is my chance to prove
myself
what if somebody attacked a different
story right because that's on you I
wanted you to be better eight years but
in trouble emotion bozos up and start
town and it's no faster and red tights
shows up he thinks he can tear down
everything I've built
I got a Plane full of brand-new Avengers
weaponry to load up we're gonna put them
out of business
we're gonna take everything they got
[Music]
you're not going to stop me
[Music]
you know em - yeah delish
you